[MUSIC PLAYING]
The single biggest
improvement your app
can make for
networking performance
has to do with reducing the
sheer number of requests made.
But rather than just avoiding
data syncing all together,
how exactly do
you pull that off?
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and if you're
looking for the optimal
way to batch requests
to reduce overall
network traffic,
then prefetching is for you.
Think of it this way--
your app makes a request
for a specific piece of data,
and then sometime in the future
it makes a request for
another piece of data,
and so on and so forth.
Each individual request
has specific overhead
associated with it.
It may end up in a weird
pattern of waking up
the radio each time
to make the request.
Prefetching is about
predicting what
data would be in
those future requests
and grabbing all that data now
while there's an active radio
connection.
The benefit here is that
each radio request
has some overhead in terms of time
that it takes
to wake up the radio and battery drain
that's taken as a result of its
keep awake time.
Being able to bundle future
requests together and do them
now means being able
to reduce that overhead
and save precious battery life.
But prefetching is a
tricky balancing problem.
Prefetch too little
and you'll end up
not optimizing your
bandwidth effectively.
And prefetching too
much means the user
is going to be waiting even
longer for the results.
So now we come to
our simple question--
how much data is
in a good prefetch?
Well, the general rule of thumb
is that on a 3G connection
a quality prefetch is about
one to five megs of data.
Of course, that's
with the understanding
that the data will be
needed and used by the user.
So you could look
at this another way
and say prefetch as
much data as the user
might need in the next
one to two minutes
of their active session.
But in honesty, one
of the biggest things
your prefetch needs
to optimize for
has to be for the speed
of the device connection.
For example, if the user
is on a 4G connection,
you may be able to
connect and fetch
12 new photos, which takes
the same amount of time
as prefetching three
photos on a 2G connection.
So modifying your
prefetching code
to take into account the quality of
the user's connection
is the best way to create
optimal fetch cases.
And it's worth pointing
out that the easiest way
to determine the health of
the network is simply to time
how long it takes for some
known piece of content
to return from a request.
With a few simple calculations
and a handy lookup table
for common network
speeds, you can quickly
determine what type of network
the user is connected to
and adjust your fetching
and requests accordingly.
It's also worth pointing out
that the real sweet spot here
has to be executing
batched requests that
were delayed to be issues, but
have been on the wait cycle,
and future requests,
AKA prefetching,
into a single
activity radio window.
That's when things start
to get really awesome.
And the good news is that
you can update your app
to adopt these patterns
without having to write
a massive amount of code.
GCMNetworkManager is a
Google play services API
which helps to schedule
network-oriented tasks
and handle batching for you.
This greatly simplifies
the implementation
of common patterns
such as waiting
for networking activity,
network retries,
and exponential back off.
Basically, it's all the stuff you need
with a single helpful API.
And when it comes to performance,
you need all the
helpful APIs you can get
and helpful videos, too.
Which is why should check out
the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns content,
and don't forget to join
our Google+ community, as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]